In July,
a very famous inorganic chemist professor
lo Jack Lewis died.
And he's actually the only chemist that I
know who's become a Lord for those of you who are not in
the UK.
Lord is a member of the upper house of parliament and
people are not elected as a Lord, but they made the Lord.
If it's felt that they can really contribute to the governing of the country.
So it's a real honor.
Jack Lewis was an undergraduate and
a PhD student here in Nottingham.
So we're very proud that he did his first chemistry here.
And as you probably know,
we keep record cards for all our students.
So here is Jack his record card with a
photo of him as he was as an undergraduate.
He started here as a student in the session,
1946 to 47. So that was a year before I was born.
And what I think is interesting is that if you look at his
marks,
he did really well in organic chemistry and even in his final
year, although he became a famous inorganic chemist,
his organic chemistry was better once he got his dog,
his first degree is BSC and it says special first
class. I have no idea what that means, but I'm sure it's really good.
And he got that in 1949. And then he did a doctorate,
a PhD here in 1952,
and we have his PhD thesis,
which is the reaction of liquid dinitrogen
tetroxide with metals dinitrogen tetroxide
is an oxide of nitrogen and 2 0 4.
And it is a really topical compound because
the Rosetta spacecraft,
which on August the sixth that's today is making its
rendezvous with the, um,
comment in space.
And it is using enter four as the propellant or the oxidizer
in its motors for the final maneuvering.
And the work that was done by Jack Lewis was looking at how
metals react within to fall when he was working.
It wasn't known that into a full would be really good rocket propellant,
but he was laying the basis of what later became
the study of the corrosion of the pipes in rockets.
And the reason why on Rosetta, when they fired the rockets,
the pipes wouldn't be blocked is because of chemistry that was started by
Jack Lewis.
[Inaudible] this.
Thesis is surprisingly fat it's partly because it is
included some of his publications after working
here, he worked to the Tomic energy research establishment at Harwell,
and then he became an associate lecturer in Sheffield.
He moved around from several,
several universities ending up as professor in Cambridge,
which is where I met him in Cambridge.
He did both distinguished chemistry and also he
was the founding head,
the so-called warden of one of the latest colleges in
Cambridge, the Robinson's college. And really,
I think he became a Lord as a result of his political and
administrative experience in developing the college and its role as the center
of science.
But let me just tell you a little bit about the science he did in Cambridge.
He was working with compounds that were compounds between
metals and carbon monoxide and particularly compounds that had a lot of
metal atoms in them.
And he tried to get bigger and bigger clusters of
metals. This was so-called cluster compounds.
And I think eventually he got one that was sort of had really quite a
large number of atoms, looked a bit like a tetrahedron like this one.
And the idea behind his research
was to try and understand how these clusters of metal
effected the reactivity of molecules that were bonded to the metals,
perhaps as a model for working out what happens in
catalysts and catalytic reactions. He was a very nice person.
And what was really good was that he was very kind to people
who were greatly his junior a few days after he died.
I got an email from one of his former students.
Who's now working in Germany who wrote me,
Jack Lewis is the person who has most influenced my career,
but more significantly my way of approaching a scientific problem and thinking
about chemistry in general, having been an early riser throughout my life,
I used to be the only group member in the lab before 8:00 AM
and would see Jack almost every day. About that time when he,
who came to the department even earlier,
would take his first break to discuss chemistry and other matters with him.
We've stayed in close contact after my PhD and wrote each other more than a
hundred letters. Most of which I've kept since then.
And I think that's a terrific tribute to somebody who's a senior
professor interacting with a student.
I should say that when I was a student,
I had quite a large car so-called Woolslair
1800 and much to my embarrassment.
Jack Lewis had the same car. I'm not sure that he drove himself.
I think it was his wife that drove.
So I had to sneak into the car park and hope that nobody would notice that I,
as a students had the same car, I was embarrassed.
It was a little pretentious that the students should have a car like that.